字幕: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Keisuke Yamashita
例えばここに 新しい技術ができたとします
これに対して様々なことを言う人はいますが
中にはこの技術がよく分からないという理由で
物すごく批判してしまう人もいます
しかしその技術が生まれた背景や
その将来性がきちんと理解されれば
その技術の使われ方というのは
劇的に変わっていくかも知れません
まさに今 生命科学は
みなさんが思っているより
ずっと急速なスピードで
変化の兆しを見せています
それに対して私たちはどのような姿勢で
向き合っていけば良いんでしょうか？
今は特にゲノムに関する技術が
飛躍的に進化し続けているという時代です
私も研究者の１人として生命科学の道に進んで
東大でゲノムを活用した研究をしていました
その中で 研究とビジネスのシナジーを
大きく生み出すような
しくみを作らなければという思いで
２年前にジーンクエストという
会社を創業しました
個人向けのゲノム解析サービスを提供しながら
そこで集まったゲノムデータを研究に活かす
というしくみを作っています
このような取り組みに
チャレンジできているのも
実は技術的な背景に則っているんです
生命科学はこれまで非常に発展してきました
過去から現在を比べて
何が起こってきたか？
これは例えば
インターネットが私たちにもたらした革命と
同じようなことが生命科学にも起こっています
電気がコンピューターを生んで
それがインターネットに接続されました
そしてインターネットが
社会全体に広がったことで
それを介して
様々なデータが蓄積されています
そしてその発生したデータを活用するために
今は人工知能が使われるようになっています
一方 生命科学では DNAが発見されて
その30億の塩基配列であるゲノム配列が
2003年に解読されました
そしてゲノムの解析技術が
非常に発展してきた —
それがここ10年の出来事です
そしてそのゲノム解析技術が
発展するとどうなるのかというと
世界中の各地で
ゲノムデータが集められていきます
ゲノムというキーワードが今
突然出てきたのではなくて
このような技術的な背景からすると
各地でゲノムデータが氾濫していく
というのは当然の流れともいえます
そして今は
いかにそのデータを活用していくか？
そういうステージに来ているんです
このように
ゲノムの解析コストが劇的に下がりました
それに伴って ゲノムだけではなくて
様々な生体情報の解析技術も発展しています
つまり私たちの生命の様々なデータ
というのが集められてきます
そしてこれからはその様々な生体情報が
加速度的に集約されていくことで
私たちの想像を遥かに超えて
様々なことが解明されていきます
つまりこれまでの
生命科学の発展のスピードというのが
今後はさらに加速して急速に発展してゆく
そういうことなんです
そしてこの技術の発展というのは
私たちに良い未来をもたらす可能性があります
私たちヒトの体の状態が
解明されて可視化されていく
そうすると実際に 例えば
こういうことが起こっているんです
[すい臓がんを99％判別 / 鬱病の診断が数値化 /
ゲノム編集で白血病を治療]
これまで判別が難しかったすい臓がんが
判別できるようになったり
あるいはこれまで医者の問診でしか
分からなかったうつ病の診断が
可視化される 数値化される
そういうことが実際に可能となってきています
あるいは昨年世界で初めて
ゲノムを編集することで
白血病の治療もできるようになりました
つまり いろんな生体情報が集まってきて
生命の法則が解明されていくと
私たちはそれを活用して今後の医療や社会を
大きく変えていくことができるんです
このような大きな生命科学の流れの中で
私は遺伝子解析サービスを
提供している訳ですけれども
現時点で遺伝子解析によってできることは
このスライドの中でどれでしょうか？
いいですか？
みなさんもう答えを決めましたか？
答えはこちらです
実は現時点では全て ノーなんですね
みなさんの予想とは
ちょっと違ったかもしれません
実はこの
生命科学の発展というのが著しい一方で
それに対する人間社会の理解というのが
追いついてない
それが現状なんです
そして今後 さらに
生命科学が発展していくことを考えると
今後 どんどん この差というのが
放っておくと広がっていきます
私たちは 特に日本では
この サイエンスの大きな流れについて
その詳細を習うことなく大人になりますし
よく分からないという人も多いと思います
しかし みなさんの中で特に
専門家ではないという方のほうが
このサイエンスの
流れを知っていただくこと
それが実はとっても大切なことなんだと
私は思っています
例えばゲノム解析技術が発展して
病気の治療に使われるかもしれない一方で
それが差別に使われたり
バイオテロに使われるかもしれません
また遺伝子情報を知ることができて
病気のリスクを事前に回避
できるかもしれない一方で
その情報を誤解して過度にとらえて
精神的なショックだけを受けてしまって
終わるかもしれません
生命科学がいくら発展しても
それを私たち人間社会が理解したり
倫理的な基盤がないと
私たちは良い未来にいくことができないんです
このサイエンスをきちんと活用できる社会 —
それを作っていくためには
この差
これを埋めていくことがとても大切なんです
今 このサイエンスが
私たちの生活を大きく変えていく
そんな兆しに 私たちは今まさに
直面している訳なんですが
これから変化が起こっていくとき
私たちは身をすくめたり
斜に構えてはいけません
変化することは受け入れた上で
真摯に建設的な議論をしていくべきです
もちろん 新しいものに対して
賛否両論が起こることは大切なことです
しかしこの新しいものが
よく分からないという理由で
あるいはこれまでとは違うという理由で
拒絶したり批判する人が
驚くべきほど多いんですが
それは違うと思います
なぜなら これまでよりも
技術が急速に発展していくからです
そこでお伝えしたいアイデア
今日からみなさん 例えば
新しいサイエンスのニュースを見たとき
この技術はまだ不完全だからだめだよねと
そういうことを言ってしまうのは
現時点の点でしか見えていない議論なんです
ではなくて その不完全さが
なくなっていって進化していくのは
もう目に見えている流れなので
そうなった時にどう活用できるのか？
あるいは
こういう新しいリスクも生まれるけど
それをどう回避して
うまく活用できるようになるのか？
そのような先回りをする視点を持って
議論をして欲しいと思います
今日からみなさんの一人一人が
そのような視点を持って議論していく
発信していく
それをみなさんに実践していただくことが
この科学技術の恩恵を受けられる社会を
作っていくことになるんです
ですので 本日このアイデアを
聞いてくださったみなさんには
これを実践して欲しいと思います
最後に私はこの サイエンスを活用して
社会に価値を提供していく
そんな事業を通して
遺伝子や生命の解明をしていきたい
と思っています
そしてそれが人や社会 — 国が抱える問題の
解決に必ず役に立つと信じています
しかしそれはどうやったら実現できるかは
まだ誰も分かりません
そして人々の理解や倫理
さまざまなハードルを
越えていかないといけないのも事実です
しかし 今日このアイデアを
聞いて下さったみなさんの協力も得ながら
私は未来に向かって
進んでいきたいと思っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）